all of you i think elect wasn't there
but uh
last night and uh i'm changing hats and
i'm speaking to you as the not the
playback actress but uh
is the director of the simon's institute
and uh i want to welcome you all to the
simons institute and uh as you probably
know
this is a place dedicated to researching
threat of computer science and in
particular to collaborative research so
we have um we've been working we've been
open for 10 years it's a generous uh
grant from the simon's
foundation
uh that opened the center for threat of
computer science people come here for
programs that are dedicated really for
research
uh that is grounded in theoretical
computer science sometimes it goes to
other fields like neuroscience like uh
physics and so forth in engineering but
really the principles are foundations of
computer science which i think you're
all
students of this discipline given the
title of the
theoretical women in theory
um so welcome and i hope to see you all
throughout the years going forward when
you do research
and uh
you know yesterday tal had the story
about her voice and i too have had
covered uh
within the last two weeks i'm totally
negative but i'm mentioning that not
just because i want to share with you my
personal experiences but we recommend
you all wear masks uh
you do whatever you want we don't have a
rule here the city of berkeley does not
have amanda and mass mandates which
means that we can't force you i think
it's a good idea the reason i'm not
wearing it because i just had code so i
have like a free ticket out of jail and
also i'm the speaker
um okay
so i was just debating a little bit what
uh professional talk to to give
here something older and or something
newer and i decided really to
give you a talk that i been giving in
the last couple years so this is not
very new
uh but i think it's sort of more general
and more interesting and i understand
that there's a significant number of
views only first or second year student
if that's correct so how many of you are
first-year students
and how many of you are second-year
students
okay so that's so i think i have it
right all right so the title of my talk
is how to address the growing
distrust actually in algorithms with
more mathematics so with more
theoretical computer science and uh as
you see i have a picture here not just
of the simon's institute but also of a
company that i call 500 and the reason
is not because of the research is
related in any way shape or form to the
work the company is doing but just
because uh i think that
uh one of the things that probably is
um
a
a big distinction
between uh
faculty and men and women in computer
science
is there a problem with the sound
something about me
maybe
touching the my pocket um
a
got another one okay
let's hope this better um
so
uh
one of the big distinctions uh is that
i've noticed over the years and that
might not be true already for your
generation but certainly was true for my
generation is that a lot of uh the guys
at some point uh also
did not just continue doing exactly what
they did all the time not that there's
anything wrong with it that might be the
right thing to do in terms of uh you
know going more and more and doing the
research but they've also diversified
their interests and sometimes they open
companies sometimes they went for
furious industry and went back
and in the spirit of exploring your
options i think it's uh interesting that
uh that was much more the case for
for um i mean it was very gender uh
different
so i just wanted to say that i in
particular do have a startup this was
very late in the game compared to my
colleagues and who knows how it's going
to do but just for
second information that's also something
that's open for you later on and
you're allowed
to think in the same way that your
colleagues do
all right so to the topic of the talk um
some machine learning algorithms so we
all know this is an old picture but this
is a conference of the world computer
science machine learning really is in my
in my mind in the intersection of these
three artificial intelligence theory you
know statistics and uh you know the only
common thing that you need to know for
this talk that when i talk about machine
learning i mean algorithms that learn
from data make predictions on data
without being explicitly programmed
um
so uh we do know that this availability
of data in many different walks of life
has changed uh really everything in
health prediction and
even
decisions of of uh what to do uh finance
economic growth infrastructure you know
how we drive where which roads we take
uh how we use electricity you know and
obviously in the areas of the machine
learning researchers mostly do empirical
work
in vision and natural language
processing
in security threat prediction and these
days of course or in some sense when i
say these days it's when this talk was
written which is about a couple years
ago where these whole questions about
policing where to send police cars
whether to let people out on bail or not
you know whether to give you credit or
not or to accept you to school or not
where it's being decided more and more
by
uh automatic algorithms machine learning
algorithms and that would cause huge
debates because
[Music]
it's correct to have bail this way to
decide whether it would send police car
that way um and uh
the real kind of
high order bit is that having a lot of
data um
means that there's a sudden shift of
power from the hands of whoever used to
make decisions before is to the hands of
whoever has enough data to make
decisions uh based on this data
so given that there is a sudden shift of
power uh it's very interesting for us i
think as theorists to say wait a second
is this doing uh being done in a in a in
a principled way is there something
radical we can we can say about it and
uh um so on one hand there's a lot of
algorithms are being developed there and
it's extremely exciting because they're
doing things
by a large extent much faster and seems
to be more accurate
and then it's been done before but
there's a very little theoretical
analysis of it and as a result of uh
many things there's a huge distrust
in these algorithms on one hand there's
this great development that it gives a
lot of opportunity for us to study an
opportunity for society to grow on the
other hand there's like a societal move
that says wait wait wait wait a second
and that's a good thing i think
so i want to talk about that and i want
to talk about how can we address that
with sort of more math more more theory
so uh the kind of perfect example for
that is the bail issue
and california had this proposition 25
couple years ago which was to replace
cash bail so this was on the ballot uh
with uh instead of you know when
somebody there's a suspect and you want
to release them from jail and if it's in
the right amount of money they'll pay
and they can be released temporarily
until trial to say that there's only
going to be decision which is i let you
out on bail or not it has nothing to do
with money you don't have to pay
uh but
an additional thing was that this would
be decided or at least
assisted to a large extent by a risk
assessment system by an algorithm an
algorithm would look sort of at the past
data at the profile of the suspect and
give a recommendation whether this
person should be released from bail or
not and by and large the expectation is
the judge would take it as a as an
advice
but we couldn't
really see if we rolled the steps back
forward a few uh years it's going to be
just automatic right that was the
proposal and uh it did not pass
so which was surprising because it was
already on the books and it was just a
question of approval
and it did not pass um surprising or not
uh
the debate was like this the supporters
said obviously cash bail is not you know
it's not fair
it's it's um distinguishing between
people on economic basis which is
usually translates to racial basis uh
why should rich people get out of jail
and poor people not
and uh opponents of course first of all
were people in the bail industry which
is obvious because they stand to lose
money but the more interesting opponents
were those who said that uh
that this is the fact that it's going to
be a risk assessment system is going to
make this worse and not better
so specifically they were saying things
like um
civil rights are the cash bails
fundamentally flawed but while
algorithms can pitch you a song selling
a toaster they should not be used for
release decisions the fact is considered
for release
will still need people of color being
held at trial disproportionate rates so
propose
position 25 is further from the existing
problem but no closer to the solution
that was uh really the grounds for why
this did not make it uh
i said that um that it was a surprise in
some sense uh uh maybe not so much of a
surprise we had a workshop here called
wrong at the root this is 2019 so as i
tell you a few years ago
uh racial bias and attention between
numbers and words in a non-uh
internet data
so they're saying
in this workshop it was mostly the
computer scientists but a lot of people
from law and policy and what they were
saying was that the pervasive use of
algorithmic risk complicates or
undermines many bedrock democratic
values so if you talk to any of the
people in law and policy at that time i
think it's changed since their feeling
was that we are going to
do away with a lot of progress that's
been done so by the fact that we're
going to replace things by algorithms
without scrutinizing them without really
looking at how they make how these
algorithms were developed whether they
were looking at bias or unbiased data
would anybody control those algorithms
and these algorithms were going to
become the new law
then now we will they will there will be
worse than before so there will be
nobody that scrutinizes it they might
make these decisions which are even
worse than what a judge would have made
before and uh
and in general the reason that they
reached this conclusion was a complete
distrust of computer scientists so on
one hand there are these computer
scientists who really want to do good so
the people interested in fairness
research and how to make algorithms more
fair whatever that means some intuitive
notion so
you know
fair to minority groups and
in in many ways of defining them or did
computational or based on uh existing
you know
uh affirmative action rules or whatever
and in the other hand there was all
these policy makers and lawyers i said
we don't trust you we don't think you
it's not that we don't even think that
you know what you're doing
but we don't
think that you have thought about the
issues enough so maybe you did maybe you
didn't we don't trust you
and
the principle was that ungoverned
data-driven assessments are creating new
forms of stigma disparate impact and
group discrimination so the operating
word here is that they felt that this
whole industry of coming up with machine
learning algorithms that make these
important societal
decisions is completely ungoverned now
um
and then you know the notion of
governance so this uh one of the
participants there she someone who was
used to be the head of the harvard law
school uh was that the way she would
define governance is that it would be
some sort of participatory process okay
uh responsive inclusive follow the rule
of law accurate and efficient
and she said
that her feeling was that algorithms
were only accurate and efficient
but there's no that you can govern i
mean you can sort of maybe see if it's
accurate with respect to old data it
does the same that predictions in the
same way that all data says and and how
fast it works but there's no other
emotions uh these other things are being
satisfied now we are in theoretical
science we're mathematicians what does
this mean what is this participatory
responsive inclusive i don't know um
so as a computer scientist okay what are
the kind of things questions that can
come up though how would how would i
think about it so um so what i did here
is i developed it is uh thoughts or
questions that come up during the
training
uh post and and future
okay so let's say there's a stage where
somebody's coming up with an algorithm
to decide bail so this is what i mean by
during the development usually they have
access to past data so they see profiles
of people who were up for bail whether
they were given bail or not and whether
during this time they committed a crime
or they didn't show up for trump so this
is like
the data
and the question of course is what what
kind of data is it good data is it bad
data
is it bias itself already um
and uh also
you know if i'm using randomness during
the development so me as a developer you
know where is this randomness coming
from how important it is in the
development of the algorithm
uh there could be many other questions
you could ask but these are examples of
questions one may ask as a computer you
know as a as a theory person another
question is post development okay so now
let's say that the algorithm has been
developed
okay one cup and it's usually companies
are going to develop these algorithms
now the question is it has to be
verified how do you verify actually that
this algorithm that's given to you
and supposedly was trained with respect
to uh
the past distribution data that is
acceptable that it actually works
that is what does it mean and then you
know more kind of interesting to me and
what i'll talk about here is what does
it mean to work okay so you you know you
probably all took introduction to
algorithms as an undergraduate and you
know we've got that's wonderful we know
what the function is we know what the
inputs are for sorting we know the
outputs are we know what it means to be
correct and then we develop fast
algorithms here the story is very
different right what does it even mean
to be accurate what does it mean to be
fair and so forth so
in other questions you can ask do you
have open access to these machine
learning algorithms often the company
that develops it doesn't want to give
open access they say we want to
com keep the rights can you
test the accuracy of these algorithms
black box access for example
do you have access to historical data to
check this against how much okay so the
question of also their verification do
you have to retrain the algorithm or can
you have access to a lot less data than
before
um
and
again the most important question is in
what form of sense are we verifying it
and then once you're done with that
let's say you the algorithm was
developed you've verified that it's
accurate okay according to some measure
that we have to define what it means to
verify that it's accurate and now you
want to use it however the population
changes the data changes the future
distributions they're not necessarily
the past distributions and um
uh does it your algorithm generalize
right so if it's an unseen distribution
what can you say about your algorithm
with respect to future distribution
um is it robust suppose that it's
adversarial and is it fair maybe there
was very little data on uh distributions
that you're gonna
minority distributions or distributions
you're gonna see in the future so these
are all totally theoretical questions
okay this is an amazing you know if i
had to choose a period to be a graduate
student this is a really good one okay i
think there's so many theory questions
um to ask
so what i'm going to speak about is some
work that i did on verification and
robustness and some of it is newer than
the others these are the three papers
this is from 21. uh and here we define
what it means to verify it's one
definition one aspect
um and then
another work
which talks about this issue of future
distributions and how do you know
a that your algorithm works with respect
to
future distribution given that it was
trained on past data and and then this
last work which is newer i guess it's
not a submission anymore this was in
pnas uh a few months ago and that is
what if you don't have enough data
okay what if you have data of an old
distribution but you may have to make
conclusions about a future distribution
can you reuse the data and give some
sort of formal guarantees but i'll spend
most of my time talking about these two
so uh
uh so there's this very famous paper
which probably a lot of you have seen
but uh very kind of intuitive this is
paper by valiant also
computer scientist from 1984 where he
gave a formal definition for what it
means to be learning he calls it pack
probabilistically and approximately
correct
um
it is in essence all the you know it had
it has in it uh a lot of what machine
learning uh
aims at and so what does he say he says
um oh my son is calling you see
no you cannot do that now
so he says given a whole bunch of uh say
there is some concept class
uh sorry c and f are the same here this
mistake says there's some concept class
decision trees i don't know neural nets
uh hyperplanes maybe just a linear line
that you're trying to learn okay but you
don't know what you know you know
examples that so you know uh somebody
gives you x x could be a high
dimensional vector and then there's the
function of x this would be f and let's
say it's a zero one it's just a
prediction whether this guy should go
free or stay in jail or it could be
accepted to school not accepted school
now this is uh could be much more
general it doesn't have to be zero one
could be some finite set could be a real
function it could be like a probability
but let's just say zero one and uh
you're given about and all of these x's
are drawn uh according to some
distribution so there's some
distribution p
where i get a lot of examples of x
chosen in p and then labeled by this f
and i would try to come up with an
algorithm or an
hypothesis h
so h is kind of a proxy for f
uh where i h is going to label x's from
now on and i want to say that there's
certain laws of this age so this is when
h and f disagree
so f is really the ground truth h is
what i managed to come up with sometimes
it agrees sometimes it doesn't agree and
when it the the fraction of this
agreement is what i call a loss and it's
all with respect to distribution p
is it is that
yeah
um so the requirement here is because
this parameterizes this law should be
small with high probability okay
and
back to what we are talking about ver
now i want to
in some sense what i'm saying is okay so
if this is my definition of machine
learning
how do i address this uh societal issue
like uh
how do i know uh and we're talking about
verification how how do i know that when
the company developed this algorithm
that's a proxy for pac learning
that
they gave me a good product
okay
so there's some uh lessons to be learned
in in to answer this question is uh from
electronic voting it seems like totally
like a segue but let me explain the
connection and that is that um the
electronic voting is one of these fields
also where
it's grounded in reality you know and
people have tried to kind of jump over
the
in the beginning they tried let's do
electronic voting you know electronic
voting machines they didn't really mean
sending electronic ballot
and uh very quickly they saw there were
there were mistakes like there were
counties where the number it just made
no sense
you know if you counted the number of
votes and you counted uh it just was
wrong sometimes the wrong number of
votes were counted sometimes the outcome
was wrong and as a result of that fairly
quickly they took some voting machines
these electronic volume machines and
they rule them out
and uh the lesson for for this okay
which is the lesson that we'll use in
the context of our question of verifying
machine learning was that there is no
way
to really check that these machines are
going to work
to to ver to give you a guarantee of the
the that the machine works
but
in short short of that what we want to
make want to be able to do is detect a
mistake
so we just want to uh so they're saying
a voting system is software independent
if an undetected change or error in the
software or hardware you know uh can uh
cannot cannot cause an undetectable
change or error in an election outcome
so they're saying you know might be
there's an error in the in the
in the
in the in the box in the box in the
software we don't know but this cannot
go undetected so if you think about the
analogy to what we've been talking about
some company came up with a bail
algorithm okay i'm not going to really
be able uh
to tell you give you a guarantee if it's
correct or incorrect but i should be
able to tell
um
is meaning if there's if the software
works there but i should when it makes
an error i should i should be able to
tell
my higher order lesson from this okay
uh is that we need a verification
mechanism
yeah so what kind of error are we
talking about algorithmic coding error
doesn't even make sense like the
prediction
so the truth is i'm giving this slide i
realized that you want me so it's in
other words in the context of voting
what they meant is a coding error
and uh although it could be also
algorithmic here and but they said i put
all that aside i want to make absolutely
sure that i can tell um a mistake if the
election has uh if it's wrong
somehow okay so they're saying i want
you have to come up with a verification
mechanism which is independent of the
machine
the coding the algorithm we use but
somehow i'll be able to verify that the
result of the election
is correct
okay so the important part was that
there will be some verification
mechanism which is independent of that
of that uh of the details of the
algorithm
so in some sense it's preaching to the
converter it's a lesson from voting but
i'm already saying i'm kind of
i started the talk saying that this is
what i want and i'm telling you that
it's inspired from
from voting so that's why i'm saying it
probably doesn't belong here
but thank you for the question so where
do we get so let's go to this question
what kind of verification mechanism are
we going to have for machine learning so
there's lots of verification tools
out there you know shivangi's worked on
them
a lit i worked on them uh there is a
program verification which you may have
heard about uh so it's like formal
methods for proving that a program is
correct there's interactive proofs for
program delegation there's zero
knowledge interactive pools there's
non-interactive zone uh proof snarks i
think
uh i don't know if somebody's talking
about it in in this conference or not uh
and the question is is this any good for
verifying machine learning
can we use one of these old tools okay
to verify machine learning so so many of
them are such great mathematics can we
verify machine learning with them and uh
the problem is that um all of these
things are for um
you know they prove that the program of
x
for example running the program on some
input x will really give you the right
answer will equal to f of x for but it
is for pre-specified f so we know what
the function is
so if we think about an interactive
proof of graph isomorphous and we know
what graphite is more what
should say yes if the two graphs have an
isomorphism
to say no if they don't have an
isomorphism with them or if it's the
sorting example you know the program
should output the sorted list on the any
on any input but the whole point in
machine learning is that we don't know
what the ground truth is so what are we
supposed to verify
none of these tools are really going to
work
that's just not going to work we have to
define a new a new setting
okay so uh what we're going to do is
we're going to start from interactive
proofs okay and we're going to modify it
so that it work so that it makes sense
for for machine learning we're going to
modify the definition so interactive
proofs uh
you've got a prover algorithm you have a
verifier algorithm there's a question
and answer mechanism and there's a
mathematical claim and at the end the
verifier says i accept or reject the
mathematical claim and we have two
requirements completeness and sound it's
completeness means that if the theorem
is true if the claim here is true
whichever it is
then
the approver should be conv the verifier
should be convinced and if the theorem
is
false then no matter what the strategy
of the prover is you will not be able to
trick the verifier to accept this high
probability okay but again this is not
suitable for us because the mathematical
claim is not clear it's not that you
know the program on x is equal to f of x
um
so there's lots of history here you know
there's lots of questions in each one of
these fields okay but none of them are
really suitable for us
uh and i'm kind of using this talk also
to give you some you know
a lot
uh
it also tell you that this is a field
that extremely rich you know there's
lots of uh systems uh
and this is a beautiful theorem it's
based actually on quantum entanglement
that has resolved some problems in
classical mathematics that have nothing
to do with quantum
so
we we're going to deviate here
so now comes a new definition and that
is we could still have approver and
verifier except our approver in addition
to just what we thought of before we
want to think of it as a learner so it's
that company that's the machine learning
and now it's job to prove to the other
entity which is independent of it in the
spirit of the election story uh that
whatever model they came with
this i'll call it hypothesis so they
came up with h was a proxy for the
ground truth okay it's a good one
okay so that's uh what is the axis what
is the input whereas before the input
was a mathematical theorem that they
wanted to check that it's correct or or
that the computation was done correctly
now the input is access to a
distribution
so what is the path distribution you
know there's these x's and there's the f
of x's which is supposed to be the
ground truth
and i want to convince you something
about this hypothesis
and let's check what it is that i want
to convince you of so that's i'm going
to give in the next few steps
um
but i want to say that the learner and
the ver and the verifier both of them
have access to distribution but it could
be that their access is different so
whereas the company that developed the
learning algorithm
um
it has access to lots of data
it makes sense that the verifying entity
would have access to less data yes yeah
i'm just wondering uh so are we proving
accuracy here or are we moving
okay why not
here we
[Music]
uh go this function f uh is so
what is this proof about is it about
proving how accurate it is with this
function x and is
sorry function f or if f is the fairness
function no okay clear the question very
good question i'm going to define what
we mean so i haven't defined it yet
okay so so this f
exists supposedly in the sky
and it's not a question of f being fair
or not f is uh in the case of baal folks
f is some underground a that's the truth
so in the case of baal you could say
well what does it mean that it what does
it mean that is the truth
the truth is as defined by the past that
you know somehow we are believing that
these decisions that were made in the
past are decisions we want to mimic so
that's the truth that's what judges
would have done okay
and i don't know if they did the right
thing the wrong thing that's what they
would have done and i want to have an
automatic system
that will do this uh
instead of the judges
yes um so
what would be the difference between the
learning algorithm and the verification
just data
okay so the
great so you can define lots of
differences one difference that i want
to focus on on the results that we did
is that uh
there could be a quantitative or
qualitative difference so there are sets
of results for quantitative and
qualitative by quantitative i mean that
let's say this guy gets a whole bunch of
random samples and so there's the
verifier but the verified random samples
are a little
of the the number of the verifiers
random samples are much much smaller
than
a significant weight so my question is
um if we have a better verification
algorithm
um
why can't we just use that as like if
you like have a better algorithm that
verifies a machine learning algorithm
whatever that is doing why can't we just
replace the learning algorithm with this
algorithm and because the a
the learning algorithm has learned
something it's going to give information
to the verifier to use
okay in order to for its verification it
could be that it was a very complicated
let's think about it like this suppose
the approval for a minute was unbounded
okay
it's not it's using more uh more uh
examples okay but and with this use of
the more examples it comes up with some
short information which is incredibly
useful that enables me now to do
verification
so it's the you it's the larger um
it's the access to more examples and
made more time then enables me to come
up with this advice a short stream that
i sent over there
so so the thing is in fact this is going
to be the main issue right in order to
say the verification is an interesting
question
uh this is the the main issue
uh that is uh can you show that you
could verify with a lot less samples
than you could learn
can you show maybe that even the type of
access you need is lower quality so for
example uh one of the results that we
show is that there are some concept
classes like decision trees where in
order to learn them you actually need
more than just random samples
you need membership queries at least in
theory so you need to choose x of your
choosing and they get back get back f of
x and so that's what's called membership
queries and not just random samples of
x's for the x but so you could ask maybe
you could verify just with random
samples and you don't have to do
membership queries and if you'd like to
have a story in your head you know
remember you know let's say in a medical
setting
a membership query might be you could
take an x and do a medical trial and
then get back if
and based on all this you now are saying
this is a good a tool but the person or
the entity that's verifying it might
just have samples of the history of
procedures done outcome you know patient
and what you've decided what procedure
to do so i got to tell you that not
everybody does research the way i do so
for me the narrative is very important
that's a little related to yesterday
so i love stories and i think it's very
hard for me to work on any problem
unless there's some sort of story behind
it that motivates it but that's not
necessarily true for everybody you know
some people you know they like to have a
very nice well-defined question there's
no story
and that's i think more true for
theorists and mathematicians not true
for me
um so i can cure story about anything
but i encourage you to keep on asking me
the formal thing um so here's the
definition
so the definition is for back
verification
is again i have a class hypothesis and i
say that it's pack verifiable
okay if there exists in a verifier
especially for all distribution p okay
if i look at the loss
function with respect to this
distribution okay so loss again as we
said before i called it loss now i call
l is the difference between uh h and f
but now i'm not going to call it f i
just call it like whatever the label was
so there's the history and x was labeled
with y
and i say i and i come up with an h and
there's a reason why i'm not writing as
uh x f of x because it could be
that there isn't an f there isn't an
there isn't a a ground truth that can be
described as a decision tree it could be
that f is so complicated and i want to
come up with a decision tree so the best
one that captures f
so what do i have i have uh access to x
and y's and i want to come with a
hypothesis that will make the least
mistakes with respect to y
okay
and let's say that the opt here is the
smallest loss i can get so out of all
the decision trees i'm thinking about
these h's all possible h's in the class
that i'm my outputs are going to be in
that this is going to be the smallest uh
loss so the smallest disagreement so
what i want now is to have the following
uh
requirements completeness is that there
exists approver for a learner that can
prove to me
such that the probability the verify
accepts
and indeed the loss of this is little h
here i think
so just not to
confuse you
too much
okay so in other words i output
if you remember the story there was the
learner and the verifier he sends him
over a hypothesis so this is this
hypothesis that he sends over h
all yes delta
oh
you could pick there exists a verifier
that's a great question uh in the
theorem that we prove it's the same
verifier so just
its performance varies according to
absolute in
delta but you could imagine that for
every epsilon delta we have a different
verify i don't know that it would give
you some strength but yeah good question
so uh the completeness is that the
the if indeed
the h okay
uh that is being that you can come up
with h's such that their loss is is not
too far from optimal so optimal is the
smallest loss your hypothesis maybe
didn't reach the optimal
but not too far from the optimal okay
then the verifier will accept with high
probability
and soundness says no matter what that
prover strategy company is okay
then if the h that they came up with is
far away from the optimal
so the error that it makes is far away
from the best er era that can be made
for an apartment for a little age in the
hypothesis class
then you reject
and in addition double efficiency which
can be defined as i said either less
query less samples or maybe samples of a
different type i'm just going to leave
it vague as double efficiency
okay
so it's
um
let's see for a second uh let's just
like see for example how this would be
worked in in in a setting so the
verifier will outsource some machine
learning tasks the approver the prover
then collects lots of high quality data
trains
some good machine learning model little
h okay
and the verifier receives little h
and
now let's say tested on the samples that
he has and he says accuracy 80 should he
accept it according to our definition
okay
um well
you know if indeed it was the case okay
that the
optimal is zero what does that mean it
means there is an h that would lose zero
it's an identical you know let's say
that it's an identical to the uh
to this uh ground truth
there exists a decision tree that would
be absolutely correct okay then i'm
saying that's a pretty good procedure i
take one over epsilon okay
the parameter epsilon is what i'm
supposed to achieve random samples and i
accept h if it classifies all the
samples correctly right because there is
a zero okay then i just check to see
if i made few errors or didn't make few
errors and according to that um
i
you know i can prove this theorem very
quickly right so if it was zero i'll
always accept if it was more than
epsilon then i reject with constant
probability
and then there's not much separation
between uh verification and learning
yes
in fact this is not going to be an
interesting case so i don't want to
answer that because i'm going to say
that the only interesting place is going
to be the agnostic one where uh how your
question is it's opposing it's an
assumption you're saying indicates
that's a good that's a good procedure
but let's assume that's not the case
because it's never going to be the case
so there's never really going to be a
simple nice clean water like a decision
tree that's going to capture the
underground underlying truth
so uh in fact then we now it's going to
start being interesting because what is
it we want
what we need to check really is the loss
of the h that i have in my hands okay
is less than or equal than the optimal
plus epsilon
so this is easy to estimate what is the
loss of the thing that i have i just
test it on samples see how well it does
okay
but how do i check
how do i verify that this is pretty
close to the best that can be done
by
by an amount of epsilon
i mean so in other words it's not that
i'm gonna ah it's not that i'm going to
this is hard to estimate that i'm not
going to try to estimate
but what i need to verify is this
inequality
okay
so that whatever i got in my hands not
too far from from the best okay
and what we uh uh show for this
definition so that's the definition so i
hope that whoever asked here
what the definition is i think it's the
third row
yeah what am i proving uh i'm improving
theorems with respect to this definition
that the approver gives an h and i check
the accuracy of the h in the following
sense if h is close to optimal
close by epsilon then with high
probability set and if h is uh far
more than epsilon from the best that can
be done then with high probability i
reject
and uh what we show basically and now
the interesting question is can you
really verify any better than
than
than learn and first of all we show that
you can ver you can if you just talk
about less samples sometimes you can
depends on the co on the concept class
and sometimes you can't okay but i think
the more interesting result is this
qualitative separation which is uh for
um so we we found a class of uh
hypothesis which essentially corresponds
to decision trees but in the language of
more theoretical computer science is if
you look at functions f underlying
functions f the ground truth they are
they they look um and we think of them
as boolean functions they are what we
call t sparse so if you write the uh
fourier representation of them the sort
sulfuric coefficients where the weight
of the function lies on and it's uh it's
a it's um
what we call t sparse so this might be
only one coefficient that's dominant in
the decision or there's an increase at
least t t sparse
so um this is a fun the kind of
functions that have been studied in
computer science and machine learning
this is this famous paper by kushi
levitz in a consort that shows how to to
learn
such functions okay from access to the
function x f of x and what they show is
they use membership queries so if you
can give x and get f of x they can learn
this representation of the function
these fourier coefficients and this
decision trees are captured by that
in addition uh
essentially there's a there's a proof
not uh that you need membership queries
what do i mean by a proof it has been
shown that unless um that h is not
packed learnable from random samples but
it
is learnable for membership queries
unless a problem called learning parity
with noise is easy i'm not going to say
what that is there's some mathematical
problem people worked on a long time
which is learning parody with noise it's
also using cryptography we kind we
believe it's hard if indeed it is hard
there's no way that that random samples
are enough to learn these kind of
functions you need to really choose the
x and get f of x back
you're doing some sort of binary search
there so you have x and you have x over
2 and x over 4 and you always follow
these x's you need
to find f of x why is that interesting
to me because we will show we did show
that h is pack verifiable
by approver that needs membership
queries but the verifier doesn't
so the verifier it's enough for him to
have random samples so that's a
qualitative difference between the
approver and the verifier so it's easier
to verify
again the verifier is independent of the
approver he just asks questions from the
proven approver must answer and you are
sort of checking
the key idea is
that
what the verifier really is doing is not
learning the concept again he is just
checking
inconsistencies of the proof so in a
sense you would like to say you want to
reduce the problem of the proven may be
cheating cheating in the sense that the
hypothesis it came up with is much
further from approximation is much worse
than this underlying function that
by epsilon okay
that's what he claims and you are going
to catch him in a lot
if that's not the case
so there's going to be some protocol
where at the end you'll in some sense
the burden of the proof is on the
of the on the learner
we say there is a procedure you can
follow to convince me to accept but if
you don't
follow the procedure and your age in
fact is not a good one i will catch you
now you
we have yeah the power of
in this particular case um
just in general
so i there are quantitative separations
but it depends on the class the
hypothesis so when i say not always
this is really sort of the kind of
theory cheap thing which one hates and
as you show that if you define these
hypothesis class randomly there is a way
there are hypothesis classes where you
show there cannot be quantitative
separation but then there are some more
natural ones where there are sort of a
lot thresholds in the line things of
that sort
okay
um all right so in some sense after my
entire build up like we're gonna really
change the world
um maybe that you don't like it in the
sense that this is a formal mathematical
definition it captures something okay it
doesn't capture that this is absolutely
the fair hypothesis and so forth but i
think that the more important message to
you is that you could talk about other
properties like fairness like robustness
like whatever it is you want okay define
them formally and then try to show a
protocol
to
to verify
and i i think that's the beauty of this
is that it's you can define what you are
going to show okay
um
okay so there's a bunch of questions
about this before i move on to
robustness uh
so uh the algorithm that we gave for
example for that last result accesses
this h uh in a black box manner
and i feel that's a good thing because
sometimes these companies that learn um
it is a good thing it's it's better it's
it's a stronger result if you access it
in a black box manner than in white box
and it also satisfies sort of the
reality that often people don't want to
just give you the code uh
maybe they commit to the code so maybe
and then they prove to you that uh if
they ran this code on an x that you you
are asking them this is what they would
give maybe in a zero knowledge way or
something like that
a
um it's interesting that i motivated
this whole thing with a bail example
right and you would think if you really
wanted to
bring this to practice
this is very different than legal norms
you know you know if i gave us your
knowledge proof that something is true
how would the courts actually accept
that you know um is this acceptable is
not acceptable very interesting question
different research area how these
our notions you know play with what a
norm is in in a courtroom
uh another question you could ask is
where is all this randomness coming from
the verifier of the approver prover i
can't control but verify i can't but i
want to make sure that the randomness
i'm using is good enough to catch a
mistake and again when you transfer this
to the real world i think nobody pays
any attention to those questions
except in cryptography where we have
examples of people generating rsa keys
using some sort of randomness procedure
that it turned out that lots and lots of
the keys where in the internet where
like uh two primes like p and q where
everybody had the same p in different
queues now
very simple calculation is you take
you know p times q and p times q prime
you do a gcd algorithm greatest common
divisor p comes out so that's not secure
so uh and the point is that they
generated that p using randomness which
was kind of shared by everybody so this
is questions that people are not asking
but i think you know they oh we should
ask
okay um and finally just about that
legal thing that i said that whether
they would accept it or not if i give
evidence or i give zero knowledge proof
that's the least of it it's not even
clear
how courts will um address uh
probabilistic reasoning
so
you know there's a lot of kind of
interesting cases in the past that
there's this article statistics in court
incorrect probabilities which is a lot
of fun to read where cases where people
were
arguing in court say the probability in
order to accuse someone they're saying
they
were faulty let's say in a medical case
same because the chance that this thing
would have happened by itself okay is
extremely low and the reason in the way
they would argue chances is by using
sort of like a product law you say
what's the probability that this would
happen and this would happen this would
happen now these things aren't actually
independent in a lot of these cases you
can see that they're not independent at
all so to use the
product law to get a very very small
probability at the end that something
would happen unless there was bad
intention it's just not the right way to
argue so
we're gonna then argue about zero
knowledge proofs but probability of
learning about you know
so so uh so learning to evaluate
statistics is key
you know i think in any kind of court
setting and i bet the future was gonna
see a lot more statisticians
testifying or maybe even understanding
by
people with legal training about what do
probabilities mean at least to detect
possible mistakes to know that there's a
product law and there's a question of
independence okay i'm done with this i'm
going to move on to robustness okay
so robustness was the question whether
the past the distribution that i have in
the past and i learned
a
how is that going to uh fair with
respect to future distribution
and they might be adversarial or not i
let's just talk about it as future
distribution so again remember that
definition given a bunch of examples
that pack learning from the past
i want you to do as
well on those same distribution
the thing is uh so the training
distribution and the testing
distribution are the same in the
definition i mean valiant realize i mean
it's kind of obvious that if i haven't
seen any example according to this
distribution i can't require the
algorithm to do well
right so
if i saw distribution p i will do well
with respect to distribution p
but uh this is just not the case so uh
there's something called covariative
that's where the distribution is shifted
so it's really just a new distribution
so for example you know people gives
this example about covid um that there's
sort of a
what a normal lung would look
look like
i had to cover it in what it looks like
now where most of us have head covered
so uh
you don't understand how much of a
relief
because for two and a half years i've
been waiting for that red line on the on
the test tube finally it arrives okay
it's not like i haven't turned into a
beast or something
or so but these are very different so if
you have uh something to diagnose lung
cancer on those old photos they're not
going to really work on necessarily on
the new ones you know same thing is
about you know u.s data this is how you
guys write a one this is how you would
write one internationally that's how i
learned to write a one what if you have
a thing trained on that how is it going
to do so these are natural kind of
shapes there's no adversary intended
it's just a different
data set at this point
which is related but not the same
and
this is on one hand but
and then there's this whole research and
machine learning about adversarial
examples somebody just wants to feed
into the machine learning algorithm some
input that's going to trick it okay so
that's a much worse case so there's the
test there's the distribution you
learned on and then there's the
distribution you're tested and somebody
has actually tweaked it
especially to to fool you so it's not
just long pictures that have changed or
numerous in israel versus the u.s
and what the typical machine learning
approach is that they say i'm going to
make and this is where a lot of progress
in the last four or five years they say
i'm going to make my algorithm robust
to what's called perturbations
perturbations is
the adversary surely what they've done
is that they took
uh old uh
distribution then they tweaked a little
bit in order to trick me and for those
for that kind of adversary who was into
like perturbing natural inputs i'm going
to make my algorithm robust
the thing is that
that really is not what modern
day adversaries do so i think there's
this famous picture of pandas where they
put a little barcode on it and then
everything changes it becomes i don't
know a plane or whatever uh
but the point being is putting a a
a bar code on a picture is not a natural
perturbation obviously
so um
um thinking sort of as a worst case
analysis or cryptographer we want to say
that
protecting machine learning against
adversary attacks
or
or uh making it generalizable to general
distributions okay a should be with the
idea in mind is that they it's not that
the adversary is cooperating with you
because they want you to publish papers
the adversary is doing what they're
doing and you can't assume how the
adversary behaves
okay so uh
this one we do in the second half of the
talk
okay
so here's going to be the working
example the working example is that we
don't talk about neural nets or decision
trees something much simpler than that i
get examples on a plane
points which are labeled either pluses
or minuses and there is some
uh way to define passes and minuses
which is just a line okay or hyperplane
um
a half space and uh
when the training distribution so then
comes these points which are the test
and let's say they distributed in the
same distribution
as before then no problem i run my
machine learning algorithm i come up
with an h it's probably it's not f
but it uh as long as these black dots
which are the testing rather than the
training are distributed this way it's
it's going to be a good
pac learning output
but um what happens if uh
it's not the case so the black dots now
are some are distributed like before but
some all of them are in here and i've
never seen any example in this region in
this gray region
so f1 and f2
are really just as good as each other in
as as my candidate what i'm trying to
aim at
so the point of this slide is saying is
that when the training distribution is
different in the test distribution which
is the case here because there's a lot
of dots here yeah
then it's impossible it's not a question
that i am not smart enough it's just
impossible there's not enough
information to distinguish between f1
and f2
so what we're going to do we're going to
define again a new a new model to add
this to address this is that first of
all we're going to allow the classifier
to
either
this h that i'm coming up with it's
going to either say yes
no or i abstain so i've added i abstain
into the mix
and moreover it turns out that that's it
you must okay that's not even going to
be enough
for the kind of results that i want to
prove
i'm going to show that even that's not
good enough because
you know in a white let's say it's an
adversary
and they know that i've answered
incorrectly on this uh
test data
then uh so i'm thinking about an
adversary that actually knows the f and
even knows the h that i'm using and now
in giving me future points to classify
then they why not bunch all their future
queries right next to a mistake so
they're going to make me make mistakes
all the time
okay so what i'm going to add i'm going
to say
not only that i allow the algorithm to
say yes no or i abstain which was not
allowed before
but i'm also going to require that my
algorithm has access to unlabeled test
examples so let's think of it this way
let me give you a story
i think we're talking about classifying
youtube videos as offensive on outfits
okay and this is something that's done
by youtube when they accept a youtube
thing to post so there's all the past uh
examples of youtubes which were
offensive not offensive that's the label
data now come new uh youtubes
and do i uh what can i do maybe now
they're like really very tricky and they
can get around whatever mechanism that
was detecting pornography or hate speech
or whatever okay what i'm saying is
before i post them or before i decide
whether this is a yes no or abstain
i want to wait for i want to see for a
while i'm going to assume that i get for
a while these a bunch of examples of
this new type of uh youtube and only
then i'm going to output my classifier
or update my classifier another example
is say you're in a medical procedure
setting
so uh instead of deciding to operate not
to operate or abstain okay you're saying
i'm seeing new patients now they look
different okay i'm seeing a whole bunch
i'm gonna have maybe a new procedure
theoretically speaking my assumption is
one i might i i allow myself an easier
job that is i'm allowed to abstain and
two in order to make the decision
whether to say yes no abstain i also
require the ability to see a whole bunch
of examples
for the future distribution
unlabeled ones
so in the past i have x's and f of x
in the future now i get also a bunch of
x primes from the new distribution which
are unlabeled and now i'm going to
output a candidate hypothesis
which can handle uh examples from this
new distribution
okay so that's the definition so the
definition of the model then is
i'm going to call it pq learning p for
the old distribution queue for the new
distribution and um
this is in this paper with uh yael and
adam and
omamoto which is who's a graduate in
the toyota institute
uh again we're going to be given labeled
examples but we're also going to be
given examples for uh
a new sorry this should be testing
distribution so um
okay
so uh yeah
no it's different than that because uh
my new ones i don't get labels for them
so it's not
but i am delaying the decision
but uh the decision that i'm delaying is
uh not it's going to be a little bit
different decision so in other words
it's not just going to say yes or no
it's also going to allow to be upstate
which is something that wasn't required
before
um so the pq learner is going to have to
output a hypothesis and also a
description of the set s before you're
just in the process s where it says this
is where i answer this is what i don't
that's just a formal way of saying that
he can say i don't know so in advance
he's going to say this is the region
where i'm going to give you guarantees
else i will say i don't know so i'm
going to specify that in advance so
that's a part of the output
okay so i'm going to only answer yes or
no on x's in s and i've seen everywhere
else
and what i would say that a good pq
learner is okay so that okay so this is
what i've described what the inputs are
i've described what the outputs are now
what is it that i'm gonna
define as a good pq learner a good pq
learner is one where
the rate of abstaining on distribution p
so in other words if the
your new distribution and your old
distribution are the same you don't want
it to abstain
that would be like it just says i don't
know
the end okay that's a good no you want
the rate of abstaining on that to be low
you want the rate of error on the future
distribution okay
to also be low and
essentially in order to to bounce to
bound both of them what i'm going to
say is that i want that the sum of the
staining and the loss be less than
epsilon
okay so in other words my algorithm is
gonna sometimes abstain sometimes going
to make errors i don't want to make too
many abstain in too many errors and i
define with respect to these different
distributions in some sense who cares
about the past you really want to care
about the future you want to say that
you
your rate of abstaining is small and the
rate of loss is small so you could have
you would like to have q's here but the
truth is if you have p that is that
actually implies something about p
uh sorry if you had about q and that
what did it
that is related to the difference
between p and q but never mind that's a
detailed question yeah you just turned
that abstain into a loss
stating is that i said i don't know
okay can you just add on those points is
that
wrong
you just need
if you just agree to make uh get it
wrong on those points
yeah
is that change
so uh on the p points on the p so in
some sense if i never see p in the
future i could i don't care if he's
right or wrong wrong on it what i care
is if you're right and wrong on the
distribution that i will see
and uh for for the ages where i say uh i
would like where i actually give an
answer
maybe yeah
is there a mathematical difference
between uh
how abstain p is calculated
so loss is calculated by just the
difference between
my hearing aids theory is the lecture
goes on yeah okay so uh laws
so loss is calculated by the difference
in hx and fx right
um
hey by the probability differences
between are you asking about what's in
the parentheses here uh no i'm asking
what is the
um like magnifice like what what is
abstain mathematically um
formalized what is abstain is the
probability that uh the h on x is
different than f of x where x comes from
p so why not just like if i just started
looking at the difference
the probability that uh h on x for x is
p says i don't know right so
um like
just if this is the function that we are
trying to minimize yeah whatever then
there is no like what is the
mathematical difference between loss p
plus loss q versus abstrain p plus loss
q
and a if it's just an addition of these
two terms yeah then how is it so how is
abstain p plus loss q different from
loss p plus loss q
so what is i the complement of s
s has to display this thing and s has to
be a big step
you're asking why this is gonna why do i
why why don't you just talk about loss
you know how how is this particular
function different from loss p plus yeah
so you're saying why why don't you just
talk always say yes or no and uh
and uh right okay well the reason is but
i don't know how to get that first the
quantity is definitely different and i
don't know how to achieve
the loss everywhere being small and i
those pictures where i showed that
sometimes that you never got data on cue
or the data that i got is very close to
something that was going to go wrong on
the show that i can't achieve
right but i don't have so that would
make sense to me if the abstain had like
less weightage or if this wasn't so what
i'm saying is you know i could uh if if
let's say the p and q are sort of
destroyed there's no support in college
okay it could be
that on cue i always say i don't know in
fact it should be i no idea i don't know
so i'm not sure then that your thing is
going to
i'm not sure how your measure would
behave
if i understood what you're proposing
because you won't
that in that case that would be terrible
right because i will have a huge loss
because there is a truth there is a
truth to this example there isn't it you
say yes and correct yes no but i have no
chance of getting
okay
maybe we'll talk afterwards because i
understand you know you're right and i'm
wrong but i just don't know no no
okay um so uh
but something you didn't ask this isn't
even a reasonable thing yeah
is it a reasonable thing to uh
to assume that i have access to test
distribution
but it's not reasonable and i claim it
is very reasonable uh and the reason is
because
first of all sometimes that's exactly
what i want i want to
have a guarantee on particular spots in
the future you know and i know what they
are and before before i actually go
about and and sort of the transductive
it's not a uh distribution type of uh
guarantee but it's a guarantee with for
specific inputs that i get afterwards
and uh another thing is that you could
always do things in height in retrospect
right so you might have an h it's not a
very good one okay and after a while you
can uh retrain it to say okay i've seen
enough examples unlabeled okay now i'm
going to adopt my assuming that this is
how it's going to keep on going i'm
going to adopt my age so the theorems
are the following and i
maybe i have a minute to flash the
algorithm so the theorem is that um you
can actually do this so if the class is
pack learnable and it you know in a
setting this time we're talking actually
in a setting where there's it's
realizable so there is a class that can
be realized um there isn't
in my class h it's in the same class
where the underground truth f comes from
uh and there is a way to do it pac
learning there's like a i don't know an
empirical risk minimization or some kind
of algorithm i can use that algorithm as
a subroutine
to output um such that for every queue
every distribution now no restriction
that it was obtained by perturbations or
anything like that so for every p and
every queue i can output this learner
in a set s where it's going to be
restricted to so with high probability
the abstain and loss is less than this
bound to hide some log factors but the
point being is that if you compare this
to what can we do for pack learning it's
d over n here it's only square root so
your error is is is is not as good
or another way to say it you need more
samples to get the same error
so uh you need like n squared over
uh d rather than n
uh proportional to n squared in n
samples where n is the amount of
training that
that you
examples that you got and the amount of
um
examples you're going to get for tests
um so here is just a apropos this thing
that i mentioned about abstaining on q
and um essentially you can show that the
rate of abstinence q is less than
obstacle p plus the distance between
them
so um what about white box so this was
just a shift from p to q but what about
the really tough one where the adversary
knows what your hypothesis is you know i
don't know maybe works in youtube he
knows what the underground truth is and
he says i am now going to advise my
friends to submit youtube which can
avoid the whole thing
and then we say well you can get results
there as well you could think of it as
two stages first the learner outputs an
h
and even and only then so youtube has an
h and then on all knowing you know inter
interior adversary
outputs some example test examples he
says on this you're going to be wrong
okay but i'm not going to i'm going to
use those test examples is it my input
right because i say that i get test
examples so in the second stage i will
output the as i promised hypothesis
which is restricted to some sns and the
description of the set s and the theorem
is that again you can
uh
for such an adversary
who gets his input you can even think
about it as getting a bunch of labels
and having some
tests and
even that maybe was obtained
by some naive person then altering them
to be me bad ones because based on their
knowledge of h and f maybe it's not
written exactly in a way that's easy to
read again the sub a the loss plus
abstain error here is loss is going to
be less than this bound what does the
algorithm look like so just i know maybe
a minute uh
just to get a sense that there is an
algorithm uh and
it looks like something like this
uh so here's the
the the
example that we were using so um
first you're going to learn a classifier
you get a bunch of training examples you
ignore this whole new thing about
wanting to see the future and all that
and you do your machine learning and you
have an empirical risk management a
minimizer and it gives you some
it gives you something like ah it gives
you some hypothesis okay in the class
a
yes yes over here some hypothesis in the
class uh c used to be h whatever gives
you a decision tree okay it gives you
some classifier and now you are this is
not going to be a good classifier for
the future that's why we're we're going
to take this guy and we're going to
modify it the way we're going to modify
it is actually we're not going to
replace it with a new h but we're going
to define s
so we're going to essentially define
where is this thing going to be
good at and can be used to say yes and
no and when you should abstain so in
some sense the whole thing is
going to be how to figure out where to
abstain
and uh so that you can get that thing
that i promise that abstaining plus loss
is low
so in other words if you're just running
it the old pathway it's still going to
be as good as a pac learner you don't
want to abstain in that case
all right so the idea is that um
you are going to go some sort of through
iterative process
where uh
you are going to use the same
uh pac learning procedure like the
empirical risk minimizer that gave you c
and you're going to use it again and
again but on a different distribution
and you're going to
let's say let's look at the first stage
you find a new using the same algorithm
you find a classifier c1 okay so there
was the h that i already found
i'm trying to
figure out the region where it should
abstain
i find a new classifier with the
following requirements that it's equal
to h for all the training set
so i'm saying this new classifier
actually is going to behave as as good
as the best one on the on the training
set but i wanted to disagree
significantly
on those points uh
which are
already in s so as right now is
everything okay let's see when we do c1
so i'm saying i want it to be really
have the maximal disagreement okay on
things that i haven't seen
and uh then i i define my set to be
those places this s is going to keep on
growing to begin with is going to be
those uh x's where uh h and uh
and c0 agree
so i've thrown away all the places where
they disagree
and now i'm gonna do this again
okay but um but the disagreement here is
on on this s when s has been newly
defined so in other words what i'm doing
is i'm saying well i want to get
i don't want to make mistakes okay i
want in the case of mistakes to abstain
so let's see how uh how much
if i'm doing really well but still
disagreeing those are the places that i
should should abstain on the rest of
them i and i and i keep doing this
iteratively and can show that this thing
will sort of stabilize after
um not a
too large this is another result here
how much time does this process takes um
[Music]
it's a linear uh
time and at that point i can guarantee
the prob the
theorem that i have outlined now what's
interesting about this is uh you have to
change this algorithms uh somewhat uh
but you this you can get results off for
unsupervised learning so unsupervised
learning means that even in the training
phase i was just getting access i wasn't
getting labels
and it could be now you know i had some
wonderful algorithm in an unsupervised
setting maybe a clustering algorithm or
something and in the future i'm getting
new points but they're from some other
distribution whatsoever so even there i
can talk about
using my previous
classifier or and then saying i don't
know so it turns out you can do this as
well
uh but it's um you need as an as a black
box not just a empirical wristband a
minimizer but something heavier so
there's a lot of meat here um but
i think more important than that is that
uh my author
adam he has other papers where they
don't
i see that there was a dissatisfaction
with our formula of abstain plus at
least by you and loss so they've changed
it to sort of have a
weighted answer
so you give always an answer
the answer but you have a confidence in
the answer so it's like yes no and you
know you
50
in some sense you know do what you like
but uh and then the the formula that
they're trying to do is to minimize uh
the error with respect to this weighted
definition and uh
they have a different algorithm also to
achieve it
uh okay so uh there's extensions uh and
this is the work that i mentioned by uh
kalai and kanade where they have some
penalty function when you you think of
it as a penalty function is another way
to think about it is that when you make
you abstain
and you shouldn't have or something uh
or when you're making mistakes and you
shouldn't have uh they have some
function
and they want to minimize that the
penalty that you get
i'm done um
i want to just say a word of caution is
the fact that you abstain is not the end
of the story because you could say well
i've done my job you know i'm staying
when i don't see data goodbye no you
should collect more data right you
should collect more data to be fair to
be
uh general and so forth you know there's
a lot of examples
involving actually women and men about
you know color and gender and the fact
that there's not enough data then you
get the wrong answers uh in our case we
just abstain so
everybody's happy but not abstain if you
want to get through a door
and you are a woman and the only idea
finds men's faces
i say well sorry i can't tell it's not
good enough so
okay
that's it so there's lots of questions i
think
i feel that as a cryptographer at least
we've got plenty of skills to deal with
them and um
these are some other examples privacy
safety uh fairness or all these things
freedom of speech are sort of societal
values but they have
now a new question when you put
algorithms into it and they require
some sort of math formulation
any questions
um so
yeah the the final thing was like the
absolute thing i think it's very
powerful in sense even in fairness
sometimes we're like okay we have not
seen this data what is fair and then
abstaining is like one way for sure um
i'm just trying to connect with uh the
fact that they can distributional
changes and how can abstaining so the
thing that you said is like if you have
more data or less data in regions and
then future in future you can have more
data but um
in machine learning often there are like
changes even in the feature set so maybe
certain kind of features were a factor
saying that they would have a very high
salary but the features have kind of
changed
feature including like there are more
female or more people from diverse
background so the entire
definition of x actually even the domain
set yeah that that can kind of change uh
and the why so yeah so it's just an
interesting question that you could even
uh another way to say what you said is
that i'm kind of assuming that i want to
that i'm maintaining the same f
but i'm not really maintaining the same
f even if there's a different domain you
know um
still
you might
think of these um in this new definition
of these liberties that you can take
where you could abstain where you could
talk about penalties uh where you can
assume that you have access to data in
in that setting um
but i agree with so i agree with you
this is really very basic uh setting
a where you are maintaining f the same
acro
you know
i think of it as maintaining the same
yeah but you want the same kind of label
it's just that the data you've seen is
different right and you're making a good
point that maybe the even the
the features
and the and maybe our societal standards
have changed you know in f you know f
decides about going on bail now we think
you know going on bail uh has a
different meaning right
this doesn't
capture that okay
yeah thank you thank you
yeah
a question
question about the first part of the
talk when you talk about uh like having
a verifier i'm wondering where your
thoughts are in terms of how it relates
to like
um this common practice of auditing and
i guess is it just it's auditing just
the empirical version of a verifier uh
but obviously in a lot of like fairness
auditing so like that you're not taking
samples that are like id at all you're
like crafting these samples that you
feel like will really reveal bias so
yeah i wonder what your thoughts are in
terms of how you presented relates to
this common practice of
um algorithm
no sorry
i think
on an informal level auditing and
verification are exactly the same on a
more formal level uh
there's an interaction going on
so
um
when you say auditing how is it done
that's my question what does the model
allow does it if you can look at h in
the you know
white box can you look at black box can
you have access to the person who
trained it to help you out
uh
here you have access to them so in
addition to giving you access to the age
they also do other things you ask them
questions that you would think that
while they were training age they could
keep around in order to
answer your questions in the future
in auditing i don't know if that is uh
allowed so the intent is the same we
want that at the end well first of all i
don't even know if the intent is the
same the intuitive intent is to say does
auditing have a definition of what it
means to be successful
i gave you a specific definition um
so it's a difference one difference two
my assumption is that i give you h now
you audited you don't have a
participation whoever trained
it and
learned it
a
but you know it's it's often the case in
practice people are you know very smart
and they come up with ideas that maybe
later need to be formalized uh
not always
questions
thank you
and